[Music]
my name is Sophie temple and I came to
New Zealand 54 years ago this coming
January and I came from England with my
husband and two little children I knew
where New Zealand was and I knew they
had sheep not a lot else I didn't
particularly want to come but and if my
husband and then there were always be
good for the children and they had lots
of pictures on the small leaflet we got
a very happy healthy looking children
[Laughter]
[Music]
when we decided that we wanted to
migrate we looked at the states look at
Canada we looked at Australia we looked
at New Zealand and of all this countries
we found New Zealand to be you know the
best place for us to go and you know
looking back I think we were right in
making that decision when we immigrated
that time it was a pity stroke in Russia
all life collapse because we have a son
and when he was when we came here he was
10 years old old and we don't want to
send him to army because it's a
compulsory still compulsory and you know
in Russia that was a lot of war
Afghanistan Chechnya all cup cars in the
world we don't want to send for what we
sent our children to the war to die for
would my children filter master letter
them to live on other countries when
know China is not good as written in the
years
IRA scene is the blood blood hit I think
I came with a working holiday visa for
one year when you're experienced in that
time but I kind of liked it and extended
for a new war before and after that a
new one in a new one in a new one and I
have been going through a lot of war
peace by now
well Jonah had done extensive research
so when he came to me and said we're
moving to New Zealand he presented a
huge folder and it had everything from
the weather to the fact there were no
spiders and snakes which was quite
important to him I on the other hand
just took his word for it and that was
that I jokingly applied for the job and
when I got the job I was like Sarah yeah
and she's like oh wow it's real yeah we
jump ship never been here before
knew nothing about a complete new place
and we were ready to get off the ship er
Littleton and we were in the gangway
waiting and there's a crowd of ladies
looked as though they'd been on a trip
to the capital and my son looked out of
the porthole is it mummy is this New
Zealand been a long trip for him and
this lady turned Rawlins I'll never
forget her she turned round and she said
have you just arrived here and I said
yes she said well the best of luck and
I'd ever thought of that lady and I
thought she never realized how important
that was
[Music]
it's a very stable and peaceful country
and we were at a stage of our lives that
we we wanted to make a move you know in
an area where that stability you know
for bringing up a family that was there
was something interesting we had no
relatives and no friends here it was a
leap of faith so my kids who sort of had
a shock when they came here when we made
the decision they felt like they were
hostage you know they had no choice to
come here
so initially my two oldest daughters
they they rebelled
you know once they came here and they
they were able to adapt to the lifestyle
here they actually thanked us for making
the decision we just decided could we
have what could we have for lifestyle
and the UK for our kids that we've got
here and the answer was now yes we'd
love them to see their grandparents a
lot more often and I'm from a Greece
call it could be viewed as us being
selfish but at the end of the day room
what's best for our children and in our
opinions it's having have a much better
of up winning here then but back like an
where we're in London for example or
another places we could have fought
wouldn't get it six weeks on the ship
and then for those six weeks you may as
well have been on Mars because there was
no communication and so and then we're
left Fiji and all of a sudden this big
adventure was about to come up over the
horizon and we had time to adjust and
the people who come now they're in
wherever they come from one day and
within 24 hours probably they're here
and so the cultural shock to them and I
think it takes those people a lot longer
to come emotionally because they haven't
had that break
well we arrived in Christchurch on the
day of the earthquake so it was even
more than what we expected and the way
that we chose to see this was that New
Zealand had given us a gift because we
were immediately part of a story and
when you immigrate you leave some of
your history behind you leave some of
your identity behind and we were part of
that story and that was an amazing
amazing opportunity growing up and being
in the time when Nelson Mandela was a
president in South Africa he had the
belief that he wanted to make South
Africa rainbow nation unfortunately it
didn't happen but you see that here in
New Zealand and you see this wonderful
smorgasbord this melting pot of an
amazing group of people who come from
all sorts of backgrounds and it's
amazing I think I feel safe here there's
a safe thing and I think New Zealanders
are lovely they're friendly they're
non-judgmental yeah I yeah I just feel
at home particularly and Rangi Ora
family enough and I do the people was so
polite after they say something and
after they say thank you and it's like
that's also weird for me because I don't
know even if you die if you're working
for someone and they say thank you after
it's like what you're paying for it if I
have to do it anyway that was my
thinking
Wow well with the time I think that they
saw thought in the first two years were
exceptionally hard I'm a very social
creature so trying to fit in trying to
make friends finding a job that took me
a really long time
really really I struggled I struggle
with it
I had a sense of I felt lost lost yeah I
was away from what is familiar to me
I felt that I've lost a sense of
identity security and I was doing very
well in Singapore job wise and I have to
start all over again and that was a
struggle because it's I felt that I have
to I had to prove myself to the people
here then I'm worth something you're
trying to fit in but you lose your
identity and that's what I did and it
took years and years for me to sort out
who I was again
so you've got a it's a balancing act you
know you this is a wonderful place and I
love it to bits but you can't lose who
you are either you've got to get in
there's a fine line though that's
because when you come somewhere
different you're bending over backwards
because you're different so you have to
fit in I tried for three years
lots of Tears lots of heartache to make
friends and of course I tried to make
friends with QE people because I felt we
were living in a new country with the
new culture new people and I wanted to
be a part of it but no matter how many
times I tried it it just always seemed
to backfire it was exceptionally hard I
think there was something wrong with me
I wasn't sure if I was smelly or if I
spoke funny or what it was but it was a
real real struggle so I was quite a long
time before I actually met a New
Zealander that I could call a friend
because you know I didn't know many
people at all and of course they were
getting on with their lives and I don't
think people understand the depth that
you've gone to and and the loneliness
you can feel however happy you are when
you come to another country the cultures
difference I thought they spoke English
and yet when I first came I couldn't
understand a lot of what was said so if
it isn't your language at all I feel for
those people greatly
because it must be very isolating we
decided not to be South Africans we
adopt our we have our heritage we have
our identity but we decided not to
specifically seek out other South
Africans we were going to make friends
with people no matter who they were
and I think that has made the difference
for us and that's broken down some of
the us and limb I knew that we had
really really made progress when some
friends of ours called us Varner that
was amazing but it took a lot of hard
work and it wasn't an easy nut to crack
you got to break away because the more
we remain and we have isolated pockets
of groups of ethnic groups it will be
also very hard for the Kiwis to break in
and I see that happening and I don't
think it's healthy for the people who
come here and also for the Kiwis I don't
think it's a healthy way to go to just
form pockets of your own culture for a
while when we arrived I felt like a
foreigner but after a couple of years
working there we felt like we were part
of the community you know we develop
friendships with with other Kiwis and
and they treat us just like everybody
else I opened my mind here I was I have
some some bad feelings about the
Argentinians when I was living in Chile
about the Peruvians about too many
people but I came here and I start to
know Indians and there are the same like
us you know the same with the Chinese
people and I will sit there you need to
get involved in the community does for
me is one of the main points that's why
with my partner we start to grow up in
that way trying to be part of the
community getting ball try to talk with
the people don't get racist or done
separate from the rest
sometimes when you enter into a room
and there is silence an invisible
barrier that who's going to approach
first what do I see
you know Candice persons understand we
can that person speak English so that
that's the fear yeah that the invisible
wall yeah and who's going to break
through it's an exceptionally hard
transition you know I mean ladies all
the time that have been here for
different periods of time and I actually
see that oh we've just arrived in the
nine months down the line it almost get
a gray look because it becomes quite
depressing and quite soul wrenching that
initial process but you've just you've
got to hang in there and give it some
time when I had my first trip back to
England and I can remember being on the
plane and it goes follows the Thames up
towards Heathrow and I remember sitting
there thinking oh god I'm home and
that's how I felt that I was back in my
roots and I was home back in step again
and then when I got the plane back again
I had the same feeling when I got back
and I thought oh wow because I didn't
know I'd feel that way I thought this is
I'm lucky I've got two homes I belong in
two places so I have to embrace both
don't you don't have to get rid of one
to belong to another they laugh are oh
my accent Matt I love all the accent as
well the Kiwi accent sometimes it's
always like you know we do my work mates
they are very cool so we we have central
heating in Russia everywhere central
heating come here look born so this was
one of the interesting shock as well for
us and they feel like sometimes in the
winter it's a woman outside and inside
so when our neighbours over time open
the morning their windows and the
winters and what they doing so but then
I understand because humidity gone and
it's getting become warm people are so
honest you know there's no such thing as
trade being the Philippines coz it's
it's amazing to me that you buy
something online and there actually
and you pay somebody who haven't they've
been seen you know and vice versa you
know so I mean people take you on your
word yeah it's something that's very
important being a foreigner or being an
immigrant there's a lot to learn so just
better embrace it and you know and if
you have some negativity coming to you
just think that this is not something
only that happens from country to come
from nationals from some people from one
country to you that it can also happen
from someone from crisis the world
Auckland for example yes being an Asian
being a woman and being a Methodist
minister it's still a struggle because
you still have to work doubly hard you
still have to bend backwards to say that
I am capable of doing this job because
you are put in a mold that Asian women
perhaps walk ten steps behind their
husband and submissive and Katya I am
trying to take on a leadership role so
it is still it is still a struggle
there's still assumptions you know when
I was applying for jobs in dairy farming
and as a manager you know oh I'm always
struggling uphill if I'm competing with
other Kiwi farm managers what the job if
you know what I mean there was even a
situation where I was where the employer
wanted me but he didn't hire me because
he was concerned that the other
internationals in the team won't take me
as their leader and that's the only
reason he he picked the other guy
unfortunately they are some biases
around South Africans in the workplace
and you had to work really really hard
to create relationships and but their
trust so their people we're willing to
work with you and willing to share
information
and willing to to adopt you into the
work as you could say you know
underneath we're all just human beings
and the similarities that we have are
much more than the differences we maybe
look different we might be sound
different but when you really get to
know people there are people the same as
you are
yeah I want was other than Nutella I
want to apply a new visa and for my wife
and a second daughter come here with me
with me with us this is my dream I dream
where I want to be a farmer in New
Zealand and the puter House Hotel yeah
it is my dream yeah I think New Zealand
is blessed and the only the only I mean
as a country as a place to you know grow
your business as a place to to emigrate
but the distance is the real is the real
deal breaker it's yes you have to use
you have to realize that arranging for
coming back is it's quite tough I don't
think it made us who you are I don't
think it made us how much family you
have or having gotcha
it is a hard process it's not easy to
transition it's a really hard people say
that we're deserting our country well I
say you've got to have some serious
serious still Kahuna's to move over to a
new country and I don't think it matters
what the country is or where their
country as it is really really hard the
journey is going to have peaks and
troughs and you sometimes go through the
depths of despair in these troughs and
to accept the fact that that's normal
and to realize that yeah you might just
have to reach out to that social group
that you've created to help you through
that trough I feel that for my kids here
they are are Kiwis
and they will always be huge and they
will also have that root of both they
tell inside at the Venezuelan side
they'll like myself I am I am both you
cannot deny your side for both and
they're going to be New Zealanders and
they will have both and it's I think
it's also upon us to give them those
roots to have the connection with those
roots I think there's so many layers to
the onion so I don't think you can ever
say you've cracked the nuts but I can
say that we feeling comfortable in our
own skin and we absolutely love this
place
that we have chosen to be part of and I
think you constantly have to give of
yourself and you constantly have to give
back to your community and invite people
and it's not going to happen just by
itself yeah it took seven years for me
to accept that it was not initially my
decision to be here but I guess I let go
I wasn't going to let anyone in the last
two years have totally changed
everything for us I have lots of QE
friends now and they're awesome when you
first come you just need that lady that
I met on the boat you just need that one
kindness
you
[Music]